weaver wanted to this year he's made
four starts a four five seven era
pretty good whip of a one point one one
twenty one and two thirds innings pitch
only 19 hits given up
fastball cutter curveball and change
rarely does
doesn't even throw his curveball at all
anymore and so basically a three pitch
pitcher but
his fastball command is his key he's got
to be able to command that both
inside and outside and then work the
change up
once he does that that's where he's
successful lefties 182 against him right
he's 260.
bounced over the mound
easy start for luke weaver yeah perfect
defensive positioning for the
diamondbacks ahmed right there
3-1 now 79 career games against the
diamondbacks story has 20 home runs
the 3-1 pitch hampson not going the
pitch
ground ball to shore double play ball
ahmed bond is second to van meter and
then on to first
and ending any double play so weaver who
struggled with his command gets a double
play ball off of
the badass story and the rockies turned
away in the top of the first d-backs
look at antonio cenzatella
to deal with senza when he's on you can
get a lot of grout balls he'll be busy
in that infield
yeah he's eighth in the national league
right now ground ball percentage
that ball squared up the center and it
was hit so hard
that daza comes on and makes the catch
a line out to begin now he's fortunate
because that
is a pitch you can see just a reaction
escobar he said i saw it
and he got the barrel on it he just
worked underneath it two outs
fortunately
for sansa that'll bring up david peralta
david has it safely in three straight
games nine of his last
ten he has really come around zatella
now over 20 pitches in the first
pounds off the glove of crone and into
right
van meter are going to put the brakes on
at second and has to hustle back in
there
charlie's got five assists in right
field now goes a two-out hit for peralta
two on down for a vote
25th pitch in this inning weaver threw
only 12 pitches in his half of the first
and this will get him out of the inning
he'll run to the bag
easily that will end the inning a hit
and a walk but no damage
no score after one the chuck the last
couple of games has emerged from a funk
he steps in with two on and nobody out
and this ball lied down the line fair
ball
ryan mcmahon will score easily cj crow
the trail runner he's
about halfway around now he's gonna
retreat and go to third on an rbi double
by
blackman one-nothing colorado charlie
blackman had
three hits in the series against the
giants and they all went the other way
one was on the infield one a double to
left center
this time he reaches down and pulls the
breaking ball
just flicked the bat out there topping
it out with the bases full and two down
tapia's got an 82 percent contact
percentage rate and the pitch
and the line drive it's going to be a
tough play escobar gets to the bag
in time to beat blackman to win the unit
that was not an easy play they had a lot
of backspin on it
first thing eduardo had to make sure of
he caught the ball of the bounce
garrett worked out a walk in the first
inning story unfortunately hit into a
double play behind him just attempt to
play the rockies of him to this year
this is line to right fair ball into
that corner
garrett is really fast he's taking a
look thinking about
three and he'll pause at second a lead
off
double for hampson got six of them now
here's trevor story over one with the
double play ground ball
opposite field fair ball hanson could
jog home
story will run to second now he's
thinking about
three trevor is in there with a triple
up in colorado his second triple this
year
a little bit of a bobble too though out
and ride by
the right field of josh rojas third
inning three nothing colorado
swinging a line drive to short oh what a
pick by ahmed
goes to van meter and on to first for a
sweet double play six four three
oh leg puts it cleanly out of the dirt
on to van meter plenty of time to turn
that double play nicely done
second double play turn by the
diamondbacks infield behind luke weaver
tonight
peralta now two out hit by escobar
diamondback's third hit of the night
and he hits this one in the middle of
the field and escobar is on the move
that's gonna get to the wall the freight
train's on the tracks
he's round in second and he's headed for
third
peralta's got the triple that's the
fourth triple this season for the
freight train
diamondbacks on the board i tell you
what he's really got a pretty swing when
he goes the other way doesn't it he
really does
go get him eddie 3-1 colorado we go to
the bottom of the fourth inning
rojas gets into one way back
joshua the second for josh and it's a
one-run ball game
senzatilla trying to go to that back
door slider and it just
floats up there on the inside part of
the plate actually off the inside corner
matt peacock likes it
marshall fair down the line and dalton's
on the move he can really fly stumbles
around first
gonna have to hustle into second and
he's in there standing up he was
thinking three
it started out as one and a quarter and
then coming around
first sniper they hit right on top of
the bag at first
usually the runners like to hit the
inside edge of the bag and kind of
propel themselves
a base hit here from pavon smith can tie
the ball game pavement over two so far
fair ball down the line this will tie
the ball game here comes versio
pavon smith hits for second and it's
three to three
down that third baseline a mirror image
of our shows down the first baseline
watto singled and scored in the third
came home on that peralta triple he's
one for three
swinging a shot to right center field
that's a base hit
and it goes deep all the way to the wall
here comes van meer to score
escobar is on his way to third the
diamondbacks have their second triple of
the night
they're on top four to three that split
the gap got all the way to the 413 mark
out there
d back second rbi triple tonight
[Applause]
that's his first triple this year
another runs down there 90 feet away
still nobody out
pearl to the center that one gets down
escobar is home and it's 5-3 peralta's
third hit tonight
strike
on matt adams
ball game diamondbacks win it the
bullpen
sensational tonight and they take the
first of four against colorado five 5-3